[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rett this week at the round table of
demm lighting I'm going to be telling
you about a controversial practice
instituted by a restaurant that I would
like to get our opinion on oh okay and
I'm going to tell
you about rugby oh up I'm going tell you
how rugby
is you
know you're going to tell me about rugby
yeah I've learned about
rugby but I want you to start because
this sounds this sounds like this sounds
sweet man this sounds like a hot take
this sounds like it might be
controversial um yeah cuz I I purposely
have not yet formed my opinion about
this CU I saw I was like let's have some
real time opinion forming okay okay um
so you know I get a lot of my news from
food and
wine that's not true it's not even a
good joke but this does this does come
from food and wine unless you get news
from actual food and
wines foods and wines well that could be
a new thing it's like a delivery service
and you get like uh bananas and other
things with skins on them and we use
some high-tech printing device to like
the morning news on your bananas I think
you're talking about Laffy Taffy my
friend well no no if like Laffy Taffy
Laffy Taffy is a is a manufacturing
process that takes a while I'm talking
about day of fresh bananas we print them
what's the what's the news today what's
the news put it on the bananas send the
bananas to the homes uh banana news
banana news banan banan we just came up
with bananos no man I'm still this is
the best thing we've ever come up with
this is the best thing we've come up
with in years
bananas we have bananas they have news
you get them on your doorstep before
they turn brown you know all about
what's going on around town whoa well
whoa I I mean I'm on
fire I'm a little concerned that banan
new are bruised banan news cuz if you're
going to print the news on a banan news
then the bananas are going to be bruised
our proprietary printing technology does
not damage the banana skins it is a
laser print
it happens from a distance there is no
pressing no we're not dealing with a
ribbon my friend no pressure no pressure
it's laser etching there's no jet of an
ink it's not ink it's lasers it's
burning and it's edible completely
edible because it's just it's a little
burnt Mark and I'm glad you brought that
up well the Peel's not oh okay now okay
the first news article that this just in
with bananos first article we're going
to put on ban edible I told you this I
put them in my freaking they're only
edible if you put them in your
smoothie extra fiber lots of extra fiber
lots of extra banana flavor you need to
use organic though because and all ours
will be organic because there's a lot of
pesticides on non-organic banana skins I
hear that so anyway banan this just in
on bananos they've discovered a banana
that doesn't taste like a
um banana yes that's what I want to hear
oh gosh listen you okay well this is a
solo project yet again yet again another
solo project for bananas because he
doesn't even like bananas he doesn't
like the idea I don't hate bananas but I
don't want and I do like fiber okay name
another fruit name another fruit Apple
news oh no that sounds like something
that exists I've got it I've got it on
my computer already pomegranates are
just too hard to get
into nobody actually likes pomegranates
they just like the idea of liking
pomegranates I love pomegranates you
think you love them you think you love
pomegranate I know I love a pomegranate
you love the fruit of the pomegranate
you love the seeds if they are given to
you but the process is such a difficult
thing that you hate yourself by the end
of it you don't actually like
pomegranates I mean it's highly
stainable do you have someone who does
it for you oh yes I have a pomeg granzer
okay who's your pomeg grantier your wife
uh you get your kid to do it don't you
what are kids for r
if you get your kids to do it you can
enjoy it but if you have to if you just
start with a pomegranate and then you're
trying to be the one to process it to
get the stuff from inside well we have a
pomegranate tree do you have a
pomegranate Tizer and it yes my son okay
well then it's great they're great if
someone else does it for you and they're
popping off right now and that is just a
literal statement okay um not a well how
come I haven't had a basket of prom prom
pomegranates pomegranates delivered to
my door I'm your virtual neighbor well
it seems like they make you upset well I
I know no I've got a son as
well I've got a son who can we can teach
as well how many pomegranates you make
in these days um we're on the precipice
of I don't know anywhere from two years
ago we had like probably 38 come off of
that little tree how many of those did
you consume not enough what happened to
the rest of them gifts that were taken
around to the neighbors yeah
individually wrapped and then some of
them went bad they burst on the vine
sadly this just in on banana news
pomegranate news the ne are wasting
their pomegranates uh yeah banano I
don't think we're going to get any
better than that I don't think we're
going to get any better than
that I think we've peaked you know what
I'll then I'll start to like bananas I I
want fiber so bad that I'm willing to
acquire the taste of bananas in order to
put the peel in my
smoothie well and there's no I mean do
you put that like hard stem you don't
put that in there uh cuz that no I don't
do that cuz all of a sudden you're going
to choke on it I could though it's just
I feel like it might be too much work
for my
blender it would it it would do it and I
got a strong blender but that stem is
real hard it's a lot harder than you
think um why don't you just put flax
seed in there I
I put ground flax seed in every day
every day I needed a little bit more
this morning
apparently and I told I ran out this
morning cuz we have a jar and we keep
the flax seed in it and Chrissy was in
the kitchen and I'm sitting there making
my smoothie and I'm like I try to be
nice about it you know I'm very
appreciative of the fact that like she
she she shops at the grocery store right
like the majority of the time okay yeah
yeah the majority could be anywhere from
51% to
right let's just leave it that
100% uh we have started going as just a
little tangent we have started going to
the grocery store together oh cool more
often what do you do um I push cart good
and sometimes I'll go ahead and get
something you don't go hungry though you
don't go to the grocery store hungry
don't do that so this morning I said um
can you
add flax seed to the list I always get
I always get like a little Cy when I
start to ask can you put something on
the list especially when it's like
because it's like it's I'm consuming
something and it and she's like well I
just went
yesterday and I was like oh man now now
you had to wait how long I don't know
like a week maybe three weeks what well
it's go grocery store every three weeks
we get it at Trader Joe's and we don't
go to French people over here bagette
under the arm every
day my wife my wife rides her bike right
back from Ralphs every day with a
bagette under both
arms yeah I mean we go to Ralphs once a
week but we go to Trader Joe's like once
a month maybe once every three weeks and
that's where the flax seed is well
there's SE at Ralphs as well just so you
know and also on Amazon huh yeah there's
like multiple sources I could probably
get you some within 30 minutes of this
podcast well she got it to me in seconds
because I turn around and FL right there
she slammed it down and she was like oh
you didn't believe that I that I knew we
needed to flax seed she offended she
already knew she was offended that I
didn't I was like added to the list and
she was like I already got it okay I and
I'm like hey hey hey we're on the same
team but do you know you buy the flax
seed I eat the flax seed we're just
different positions on the team okay um
I have a suggestion for you because I I
think you've
also you're using Google keep for some
of your notes as well right some of your
notes are they being shared with you cuz
I want you reading all my keeps well
only if you do share them with me but
yes
so I started the reason I started using
Google keep I still use eote for like
long-term stuff
right really oh because you like
journaling cuz it's all in there you
everything or like certain ideas about
certain things in certain categories
it's like it's it's it's all in there
it's I'm not a huge fan of the way it
works but I'm not I don't want to
change Apple notes like stickies
basically yeah like the PO Post-its I
still use those for like very short-term
things but then for shorter term things
that I need to share I need to have a
collaborative nature to I use Google
keep here's why because you my friend
also have Google home at your home yeah
and so all you have to do is say
hey add flax seed to the family grocery
list and it automatically adds it to the
family grocery list I can just say it
anywhere in my house it adds it to the
grocery list and my anyone who who
Shephard can add Jesse can add and so
then the next person who goes to the
grocery store which um it could be me
it's not uncommon you're not above
it has the list right there and then you
check it off as you get it ch ch ch
check check it off and does it disappear
it goes down below and you see oh [__]
and so then you can be like oh I wonder
if she got flag seed and then you look
down there like flag seed checked off
the list bam I don't even have to look
in the cabinet it's on the list it's
been checked modern welcome to 2023 man
bananos it's well that's the second
article in the tech section of bananos
everyone should beab
notes not a sponsor but get to the get
to the
the restaurant we had so much fun with
bananas okay Georgia restaurant goes
viral after charging parents a $50 fee
for poorly behaved children ah Georgia
restant y about this y'all heard about
this is what now uh well they're
charging parents a $50 fee for poorly
behaved children now this is how this
all started well it's a restaurant
called tcoa Riverside Restaurant in
Northern Georgia and they are quote
according to them the home of mountain
time seeding seeding seeding Mountain
Time seeding what I don't even know what
that is and I don't mean a seating like
s seating not seating
seating the home of mountain time
seating like sitting what what is
Mountain Time seating it's it might be a
configuration of seating I I I feel like
I need to see pictures I need to know
because this may help inform my opinion
about this what is Mountain what what
how would you sit in the mountains bet
you there's a certain time well mountain
time where you sit in the seat and watch
is a time zone but this is they're not
in they're in the Eastern time zone so
it's not a time zone they're in the
mountains mountain time is just a time
being in actual
mountains and they're the home of the
Mountain Time seating I think it could
be there's a certain time of the day
when you want to sit and watch the
mountains because of the sun just
dancing off of it well they are in a
place called Blue Ridge Georgia so is
there a time where they're most blue
what is the time when the mountains are
the most blue I would think it was
either it was either the morning or the
evening uh dusk we're talking post
sunset post sunset I think that's called
dusk so mountain time comes around and
sit down at this restaurant and you
eat you don't want to be disturbed to be
annoyed by children see now I understand
why they lead with that but actually my
prevailing Theory here okay is that
there is a brand called mountain time
and they make
chairs okay so like the front porch of a
Cracker Barrel situation yeah they sell
chairs it's like well oh you go over to
someone's house and like oh you have a
mountain time chair oh wow can I sit in
it I mean I know it's not quite time yet
but it's like an be prepared
adarac but it's a little more upright
and it rocks and it rocks it rocks I'm
making all this I like to rock while
eating a lot of people say don't do that
a lot of doctors say don't do that
mountain time I disagree with gazing at
the mountains it's while the food is
digesting though you've eaten already
and then you go you sit out and you
watch the mountains but they don't you
don't want to eat and watch a movie we
don't actually know the answer to what
mountain time seaing is I think it's a
we've we've got a little hung up on it
actually there is Mountain Time chairs
and they are wooden rocking chairs we
were right and they look they look
straight out of Montana that's what it
looks like straight out of Montana I
will say the problem is is that the on
the it shows Colorado and not Georgia so
I don't it's the home of mountain time I
still am not sure if if I don't know if
we could call it the home of I don't
know that's it well they did call it the
home I'm about to dig if I buy a lazy
boy chair and put it in my home I can
say welcome to the home of Lazy Boy
seating because it's my home and I've
got lazy boys oh maybe they only have
what it is y'all they have they have
Mountain Time branded shars at their
local wow and can't get anything past
these Bo we are right
twice it's a brand I think the only
thing I canri is the rocking so I got
that part
right so they say it's the home of
Mountaintop seaing they don't say it is
the birthplace of Mountaintop seating
Riverside Restaurant in Northern Georgia
is the home of mountain time
seating and and food and wine they just
said we're not sure what exactly that
means oh they I mean they didn't even do
the research we didn't do research we
just speculated and got it right that's
what you got to do these days right just
[__] Your Way Forward food and wine
here's the thing yeah you're talking
about food and wine it's not life or
death good gracious okay um but someone
posted a photo to one of our uh favorite
Reddit threads I think mildly
interesting there's you know you don't
want to be too percolated right right
you just want to you almost I don't
think I use that term right you want to
flirt with boredom right you know it's
like that's why you're on your on Reddit
anyway you're flirting with boredom
right it's well it's just like when
you're in a gambling like you're in a
gambling uh uh Zone Zone
uh you're in a gambling trance when
you're at the slot machines you don't
want to win too much you don't want to
lose too much you want to be mildly
interested so they can just keep taking
all your money right right so they put
uh dis person uh pineapple Pizza Lover
which that's controversial they charge
$50 well here's the thing the original
thing was a picture of the menu which
has at least four fonts that I'm seeing
here love that and it just said gratuity
of $20 20% may be added to parties over
six Separate Checks birthday menu adults
are charge for adults unable to parent
and it's $3 signs right okay so that was
the first thing that people started
talking about okay yeah so they're not
charging they charge the adults for the
not not being able to parent the
children that makes sense adult sech
charge and then when you do a little bit
of digging but there's no dollar amount
right but the digging revealed multiple
sources have
reported that at least one person has
said that they were charged
$50 for their bad behavior I can read a
little bit about that
situation uh let's see uh cuz they said
$3 signs so you I mean you got to be
ready the charge which some Google
reviews have reported as a flat $50 fee
has been reported several times in the
past two weeks the most disre this is
quote this Mo the most disrespectful
owner made a huge scene in front of the
entire restaurant because our children
were running through the restaurant
quote one recent Google review reads the
children were down by the river we were
told we need to go to Burger King in
Walmart and that we were bad parents
they have a $50 sear charge for bad
children another reviewer wrote that he
was disappointed because although he
says that his children watched a tablet
until their meals arrived could have
watched the mountains don't get me
started on that uh until their meals
arrived his family was charged $50
because of my children's
Behavior what do you think about this
you've you've been to restaurants you
have children they're not kids anymore
though they're not the kind of kids that
misbehave they're older yeah I just want
to preface everything I'm about to say
with an acknowledgment of my position of
privilege oh that's always a good thing
to do link I have children this is a man
who grows pomegranates at his house okay
so many that some of them die on the he
lets pomegranates die in his yard this a
man of
privilege I have
children who
are adults yep I have two of those and
then I have one that is 13 but is one of
the most amazing people I've ever met I
think 14 I'm biased no don't don't mess
with my mind now he's 133 oh he'll be 14
in like March yeah right okay yeah or or
February whenever his birthday
is uh you know I don't have to remember
exactly when they're I know all of their
birthdays but I I can't always match up
which birthday to who person yeah this
is making you look like you don't care
so let's just move on past that you know
that's kind of my point he knows he
knows that's kind of my point knows when
I'm inan I'm I'm coasting I know you're
well pasted coasting you've talked about
this many times you talk about like
parenting I have a 15-year-old right and
that's the youngest you got another
adult you know historically he would
have had a wife and kids in a farm we
are living so large like we basically oh
my gosh we we made it through the fire
man so now we can ridicule parents and
say that you know what look at us we
made it through tablets at the table
when my kids were growing up we didn't
even have tables no I mean tablets we
didn't have
we we didn't even have phones with like
streaming stuff that they could watch at
we had tablets but they were pills right
it's like you give your kid a tablet at
the restaurant what are you talking what
is this a Tylenol situation what did my
kid do at the table when they were like
young like like pre-reading
age I I don't remember but I'm going to
say that they were quiet I'm GNA say
that they were well behaved okay now
this is speculating right quite a bit I
don't remember at all you know it's uh
I've wiped it clean it it was a
nightmare it was horrible yeah I mean it
was like you got these people that for
you just love you can't help but love
dearly and you can't get them to shut up
and be quiet and stop talking and be
don't you know it's just it's just it's
just a bad oh my gosh I'm so glad I'm
through it this is quite an
fatherhood like oh I mean just give up
on going anywhere with them don't take
them
anywhere so I can ask your opinion on
this news story okay I'm all for this uh
other people like me who've made it
through the fire of of Parenthood want
to go to places and we don't want to
remember we don't want to be reminded
huh of what happened because we blocked
it out so you know I'll pay the fee for
you for you to just get it just go to
Walmart and Burger King yes I just don't
I don't want to remember well it get
worse too it was just too hard it gets
even worse was too torturous there was
another family they don't they don't
listen there was another family uh there
that is a part of this article uh that
they had five families and their group
included 11 children between the ages of
three and eight that can't be true okay
oh God I'm I'm crying for these parents
these dumb parents don't know how to use
birth control you've made your well
that's that's five families and 11 kids
I mean that's not I mean you've got
three kids this commune of parents you
have by the way you have more kids than
the average number of kids in an
American family so you got no room to
talk and I I'm so happy and I don't
regret it a minute because I don't
remember it okay I appreciate your
strong opinion about this
um I I love my children I like to think
that I could have like a Little Bit of
Sympathy like sometimes you see somebody
on a plane a plane's even worse than a
restaurant you see somebody on a plane
with an infant and you think about was
like that was so hard my wife very
empathetic person and not just an
empathetic person but an actively
empathetic person so some people feel
some people feel and do she is a Feeler
and a doer so she will help a mom that
has multiple kids or crying baby or
something like that in those situations
change a diaper uh that hasn't happened
because that can get a little awkward so
you really probably shouldn't even offer
to do that just so you know just got
some boundaries um however perform the
himl in fact given the fact that I'm
empathetic to this situation I think
that the spirit behind this particular
fee is
that what your party does and maybe your
kids are part of your party impacts the
level of enjoyment of the other people
who are paying to have an experience so
another way to think about this is we
shouldn't just charge for badly behaved
kids we should find other things to
charge for because what about the person
who's talking too loudly at a restaurant
list $25 yes $30 maybe yes to that okay
you know to that what about the person
who I know some people can't help it but
what about the person who just has a
hellacious coughing fit
just a crazy unappetizing coughing fit
I'm thinking there's flim there's lots
of things happening you should be
leaving the restaurant you should be
outside that's a $60 fee cuz I've lost
my appetite right right yeah you know
what I'm saying I got to get a doggy bag
now because you flammed all over the
place if it leads to a loss of Patron's
appetite that's at least $60 right right
right open
sores you got a open sore throw a above
the table now you if you've got if you
got leg wounds as long as I'm not seeing
them that's fine or smelling them you
got to open
wound bandage it you got to bandage it
and then you got to put fabric you got
to make it a fashion statement because I
don't want nothing oozing through that
Gau I mean we don't listen I'm just
saying if we're taking into account
everyone's experience these are the the
loud talker thing I will say there's a
caveat to this that I want to explore
quickly Jesse if it's interesting well
Jesse I once went to a bed and breakfast
that had an attached restaurant it
wasn't actually a bed and breakfast
within the home but it was had an
attached restaurant weird and we went
into this restaurant for our included
breakfast and um it was one of those
restaurants that was so quiet that you
feel like you have to talk like this m
it's like I I I mean if I if we talk if
we were talking at this volume that's a
bit much the only other family that was
there would hear everything we were
saying it wasn't really a family it was
two it was four old older people right
and there was one elderly woman that was
at this table Yeah and we were in North
Carolina and she was talking about this
loud but she was giving North Carolina
historical information oh there you go
and so we got quiet and we listened to
the lecture free tour so I felt like I
could even pay this woman because I felt
like I was taught something but I was I
was interested in it it can go both ways
I think if you contribute to the
corporate dining experience you should
get a little
stien right so if you're talking loudly
that's a fee but if you're talking
loudly and Everyone likes it right if
you get paid you get a free meal you get
maybe a free dessert if it's local
tidbits oh a little $5 a little 10 spot
here and there you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah and if it's at this place I'm just
thinking out loud workshopping here if
it's at this place and maybe these
people at the tacoa river restaurant
have a deal with mountain time seating
this is what we're guessing so you might
go as far as to say Mountain Time
seating as a sponsor of them so now you
get a loud talker you could plant a loud
talker who begins to sing the Praises of
mountain time seating
uhuh you got like dining integration you
got yes we got built in Integrations to
the person the local tidbits local tid
oh everybody get quiet this woman at
this table is talking about local
tidbits of historical information oh no
she's talking about her chair oh she's
really okay and next thing you know
you're this family's walking out with a
couple of mountain time
seats yeah you get Commission on that
somebody's got to be what's the proper
exchange of goods in that situation yeah
I I I say you get a 10% finders fee
finders fee I mean if I'm going up going
to the bathroom if I'm encountering four
tables on the way there there and I
decide to say hey y'all need anything
are you like a waiter no exactly maybe a
little bit just in this one instance
y'all want some Sweet and Low y'all
y'all need another Hush Puppy so you
like a volunteer volunteer waiter right
just cuz with the hope of making a
little scratch just yeah there you go
just a I want I don't want to make going
to pay you it's going to be taken off my
bill okay so you go to the restroom you
stop y'all need a little sweet and low
they say yes you get it you bring it to
them then you go from the bathroom to
the manager and you say hey not to
scratch my own back here but right these
people needed Sweet and Low and I got it
for them in a little Gap when the waiter
wasn't there so you leave a little note
you know that's why I care and we don't
have any kids with us so and we're
really enjoying the Mountain Time
seats you might get a a small
discount I think about the ark light you
know may they rest in peace my favorite
movie theater they wouldn't they didn't
have a children's fee they didn't have a
children's ticket everybody had it was a
flat fee senior discounts uh I don't
know yeah probably not in
La not many seniors many seniors around
hey maybe seniors are okay but there was
this it was a subtle thing that's like
all right if you're looking to bring
your children and you're and you expect
to save a little money this is not the
place for that you know we're not
telling you you can't bring your kids
but we're de incentivizing we're we're
decentivize you bringing your children
we don't really want them you kind of
want to do a leave them at home with a
tablet they'll be okay it's just a few
hours right
right and some tater chips and and
probably liquid maybe a one of the
hamster bottles yeah yeah with some
Hawaiian punch in
it well not too much sugar you want to
regulate the sugar intake right but but
you're right they should be charged
charging for
disruptive well let me put it the way
they put it for not proper parenting now
it's a very dangerous place to start
critiquing other people's parenting
techniques but I think the the line for
me is how quickly you get the situation
under control your kid starts crying in
a performance take them out get them out
get out get them out it's okay that they
cried it's okay that you brought them
but once they start crying get them out
out of there and if your kids are doing
just Helen type things inside of a
restaurant and you seem to not be
engaged at all right to the river you
got to get take take the kids to the
river behind or behind the shed you know
to me it's I I I have kids are hard to
control you say a lot of things before
you have kids we've earned the right to
forget I haven't forgotten I want to be
clear about that when I see somebody
dealing with a kid situation I'm like
damn that was hard I have empathy but
then when I'm like well but I would not
have let this go on this long I would
have we would have gotten out of the sit
we would have removed ourselves from the
situation and a kid with a
tablet you know I wish we had tablets
man yeah I don't know about this tablet
I mean it's so easy to judge cuz we
didn't we we didn't have that but we I
mean they the kids did watch a lot of
Television though I just there was a lot
of like Baby Einstein but they're gonna
be real smart for that you
know Einstein
every parent except like EX on an
extreme end of the scale is just like
you're worn down over time and there's
there's a there you just have a Le level
of
resignation and it's like oh my God if
you just give them the damn tablet
they'll be quiet it's hard we can have
dinner because we don't have a it's so
hard to find a babysitter and somebody
that you trust and you know this that
and the other it's I I understand I
sound like you're backtracking a little
bit I do understand but write an apology
letter on banano but I'm going to
say it's so hard to not judge on the
outside I mean it's just I don't be it's
because I've forgotten that's why I'm
just oh a tablet huh so you don't want
to why even bring them oh so you're
saying you're really judging the tablets
you're you Jud I judge that tablet so
hard and I know I'm not right
I'm not right but I cannot help it I
just like it just seems like but also
let me just say parental failure it's
just it's it's just like a billboard for
Parental I know it and I know it's not
you had easy kids let's just be let's
just be real about it a lot of times
people with I had great parenting
techniques people with easy mild
mannered children
yeah have you know you had a you had a
girl first who was the oldest one who
kind of kept the boys in
line and I had to well hold on let let's
give credit with credits do it probably
has something to do with
jeans you you and Christie are great
parents but what I'm saying is that what
I have learned over time and not just
observing myself as a father and my wife
as a mother and but other people it's
just like so much of it has to do with
the disposition of the children and I'm
not saying my kids weren't not well
behaved my kids the level of energy that
my boys brought to any situation that
they found themselves in was a was a few
notches up and so and but I think that
we kind of account we didn't take them
to nice places most of most of the time
it' be like I'm not going to take my
kids to a place where Mountain View
seating Mountain Time seating we don't
need that you know we need regular
seating for these children it's it's a
tough it's a tough time so sometimes I'm
like okay you've got oh your kid is so
well behaved it's like well
that kid would probably be well behaved
in any family I mean I'm it's probably I
mean that's and I think that's that's
what I'm not saying you're not a good
parent I'm just saying that's actually
what most of the child psychologists say
is that these what yeah that's what it
makes you feel better my kids are well
behaved my kids are well behaved but the
level of energy was kind of difficult to
manage at several points in their
childhood get them out and so we got him
out or we didn't take them in like I was
never once you had the luxury of having
family nearby never once at that time
period Well Shepherd was two when we
moved to LA so we experienced a lot of
young young shepher never
once in the history that I can remember
have we been asked by another family
another
person a weight staff a manager or
anything to get our kids in line that
never happened because the moment that
it felt like it was happening we got him
out get him
out yeah it's tough it sucks it sucks
being a parent um it's also the most
beautiful and rewarding thing that
um
um well it's harder now it's because
think about it especially in La we know
I did especially when the kids were
babies we were in North Carolina you
have family you have friends you you
have this network of people that is a
little bit more reminiscent of what you
would have had like for all of human
history which is just like your kids's
being a little [__] well somebody
else that you know and trust really
really well that like lives in the Hut
next to you is going to help you
discipline your child that's like the
most of human history right yeah and now
we're in this place where we we we know
these we got some young parents here at
mythical and it's just like finding
somebody that you trust with your kids
very difficult to do in a place where
you're kind of just you don't have any
family you got good friends but like
they a going to babysit your kids you
got to find somebody who's willing to
take care of your kids
it's a totally different game people are
like on these little family Islands now
so you're like we got to get out of this
and you bring your chaos into the
Mountain Time SE let's go to North
Georgia right let's go to sit and watch
the Blue Mountains you know and you
haved for it I'm sympathetic to it
you're between a rock and a hard place
here mhm I got I got nothing for you but
but empathy as I've
thoroughly uh demonstrated we have more
to talk about but we do want to talk
about the mythical cookbook you want me
to hold it up I do so this is something
that's been a long time coming we have
incredible kitchen staff you know what
you looking you you looking you look you
look in the middle what when we do an ad
I do look I'm G put it next to you here
look over there Jamie what do you do
when we go to an ad like this I go to
the wide you go to the W yeah see I
think I watch this show sometimes okay
okay um I lived it so one of
one of the reasons that Josh has his job
you know we originally hired Josh to
help us make food on good mythical
morning but we didn't really ever know
that he was going to become mythical
Chef Josh that you know and love and
have this whole team of people and the
mythical kitchen was going to be its own
thing but the reason that happened is
because not only did we find that Josh
could
cook but he knew everything there was to
know about food and he was really good
at communicating and really good at
communicating it in a funny way he could
talk L at a
restaurant and i' I'd pay his bill
exactly so this is a culmination i' like
to pay it forward of all that brain
power and culinary Innovation that has
driven what we do here at mythical for a
really long time in the mythical
cookbook of course I mean we still put
ourselves on the cover yeah we did yeah
we did eating yeah yeah know but we're
sitting down this is B this book is by
Josh and the mythical kitchen crew and
all the recipes in there are either
recipes that you have requested because
you saw us eat it on the show and you
thought you would love it or some
original actually quite a few original
restaurants that are in that same
mythical recipes recipes there's no
restaurants yet there's uh recipes that
are original recipes that kind of have
that same mythical ethos and it's
actually just a fun read great pictures
there's lots of fun parts to read too uh
go to mythical.com
cookbook and pre-order this thing so
that you will be the first to get it
start making stuff also I want to remind
you uh rate and review this podcast
wherever you're listening to it um if
you haven't done that do it it it helps
us
out ear biscuits is brought to you by
better help you might not be able to
sleep cuz your brain is racing I mean
your mind can get in the way of you
achieving and experiencing the things
that you want to experience you know as
we're ending the year a lot of things
come up around the holidays a lot of
things that I find that I want to take
to therapy you know what I'm saying well
therapy can be a bright spot amid all of
the stress and change something to look
forward to to make you feel grounded and
to give you the tools to manage
everything going on we are huge
advocates for therapy and accessible
therapy at that so if you're thinking of
starting get better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and sued to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with the
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge find
your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com ear biscuits are supported by
Etsy it's the holiday season so we want
to talk to you about Etsy if you're like
us you're on a mission to find
handcrafted affordable gifts made by
independent sellers well whether you're
searching for custom home pieces like
cutting boards Linens and throw pillows
for your favorite holiday hosts oh yeah
you talking about us you trying to get a
gift from them yeah yeah or if you want
personalized items like purses necklaces
and seasonal jackets for your most
stylish friends and family Etsy has it
you know Etsy is a great place to get
something that you can't get anywhere
else like I've got this wooden hand
cranked I think it's called a automaton
it's that thing that makes like an
animation I've got in the Crea house oh
you got that ons yeah it's cuz it's like
a handmade craft that you can't just go
to the store and get it I love that
thing whether you want a handmade craft
or you need something for that home Chef
in your life like serve wear and
cookware or style pieces like Rings
clutches and seasonal jackets for that
Trend setting special someone Etsy has
it for all budgets and for any gifting
Mission are you new to Etsy well use
code holiday 10 for 10% off your first
purchase that's code holiday one Z
maximum discount value of $50 expires
December 31st 2023 see terms at etsy.com
terms for handcrafted and affordable
gifts for everyone on your list Etsy has
it shop etsy.com ear biscuit is
supported by manscaped Mary balls Miss
from our friends over at manscaped the
holidays are approaching but what if I
told you that the celebrations are
starting early this year keep calm and
let your balls jingle this season with
manscapes brand new performance package
5.0 Ultra featuring the new lawn mower
5.0 I've been mowing the lawn with the
lawn mower uh 5.0 Ultra oh yeah it's
kind of become my weekend thing yeah
that's my weekend thing you know cuz
it's like you feel like you've got time
to just stand there naked in front of
the mirror and just and go to work right
um I don't know it's giving me a new
level of confidence you go to work so
then you can go to play right yeah I
mean I don't know I feel like I'm
getting I'm I'm more and more every day
I'm photo ready manscape
okay manscapes performance package 5.0
Ultra is the ultimate bundle for the man
who deserves it all included in this
special sack is the lawnmower I keep
giggling through ad but I believe in it
um is the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra the weed
whacker 2.0 ear and nose trimmer which I
also love manscapes liquid formulations
which are great and two free gifts the
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra features two nextg
blad heads a standard blade trimmer for
taking a little off the top and a new
foil blade to go for that smooth finish
wherever your heart desired the weed
whacker 2.0 nose and ear hair trimmer
features proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
presence and all of these things are
waterproof the gift of manscaped doesn't
stop there the bundle comes with two
free gifts manscapes boxers 2.0 premium
underwear and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag
get 20% off and free shipping with code
ear at manscape AP .c that's 20% off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code ear manscaped get your jingle
balls ready for the
holidays this past
weekend I did you have something else
you wanted to no not about that I have
another thing after you tell me about
this but oh another thing but I might
say got you save it um this past weekend
we visited Lincoln at who's that it's um
it's a former Child of Mine who's now
I've already forgot about him once they
leave especially other families go I
forget I forgotten get out of here su he
he's a successful College freshman well
we're still early so far he's doing
great dude and I'm so glad well I'm
happy for him it's um it's good to visit
him he's he's liking his roommates he's
got three of them and uh when we went
down there it's legal yeah it's um the
room is zon for four BS
yeah and um all the roommates parents
came down for the parents weekend so we
were all hanging out getting to know the
other parents and um one couple the mom
is from South Africa and uh it just so
happened to time out that it was the
World Cup rugby World Cup finals okay
that Saturday and so she invited all of
us to this Irish bar Irish Pub okay to
yeah I don't know rugby yeah yeah they
do that they're going to be showing the
rugby game at the Irish bar yes
definitely even though Ireland got
out and um so we went there we showed up
we spent a few hours watching the final
between South Africa this is why she was
she couldn't miss it uh just very very
enthusiastic okay yeah about her rugby
um against the New Zealand All Blacks
and this is the World Cup Championship
oh yeah this is the
culmination of rugby them and I
witnessed It Best in the land I got to
tell you if you're going to be
introduced to the realm of rugby I don't
think there's any better place than a
brackish Irish Pub with someone who's
passionate about it with someone who is
passionate yelling all types of stuff
okay good gracious any South African
curse words that I should I believe so I
definitely believe so okay it was
awesome okay and uh yes I I definitely
recommend an Irish
coffee with a oh yeah is that is that
coffee with Bailey I didn't know about
that until I got there was good like a
uh iced one I got a frozen one cuz it
was kind of hot is what is it is it like
a is coffee I didn't do that on Burgers
baile
hot yeah it's a well it's whiskey and
some sort of minty stuff and coffee and
cream am I missing something uh the mint
is interesting a lot of times they don't
do that one typically it's uh it's
Jameson coffee and uh Bailey's yeah and
they usually do a little whipped cream
on top that's what it great it was
fabulous so fabulous and that that
always
helps and um let me explain to you now
that I've learned everything there is to
know about rugby now were you just
learning as you watched or were you
having it explained to you and who was
explaining it um her husband at the very
beginning she probably so into it you
can't you don't want to get somebody
who's so into it to have to be
explaining the rules like this is the
moment for her of like she's been
following this her whole life her
country has an opportunity to win the
whole thing there was a little bit of
explanation somebody with a little bit
less skin in the game needs to explain
the rules first five minutes and then
then it was over I popped up uh a little
Google search at one point but for the
most part I just observed and learned
everything I need to know to tell you
everything that you need to know about
rugby I know a little so I'm going to
see if what you have when your knowledge
of watching it one game one match
surpasses the little bit that I know it
well it will immediately and then it
will be comprehensive so are you ready I
mean you need not
Wikipedia after this okay all right all
right you're familiar with
soccer or what everyone else calls
football okay you're going to start with
soccer okay hell yeah all right all
right you're not going to start with
American football okay all right
absolutely not R okay I am not okay that
would be a huge
mistake okay right because they can only
touch it with their yep feet
Z all right picture soccer or as I'm
going to call it football okay okay and
picture people are just you know just
kicking the ball they their footing it
around on this on this big green patch
I'm aware of a field yeah and uh then
picture all of a sudden one person
deciding to up and I'm not talking about
a goalie here I'm talking about just a
player out in the middle of the field
picking up the ball and just starting to
run with it and then picture everybody
on the other team getting
extremely
angry like appalled oh my God don't
understand the most fundamental rules
of football is that you don't pick up
the ball with your hands we're going to
get you we're going to get you and we're
going to hit you with as much force as
we can muster when we get to you now
this
ball if you were to reference another
type of ball that I might know what
would you would you say a soccer ball or
would you say an American football like
iture is it spherical or is it more
oblong picture football player which one
does it look like who's decided to pick
up this soccer ball and he's grabbed
he's grabbed it with so much force and
intention that he's turned it into like
an egg shape that he smooshed it into
some sort of an oblong egg shape kind of
an oval shape almost pointed at the not
pointed not pointed it's not it looks
like it could be if they just like
modified a little bit more ball that has
been smooshed into a permanently oblong
okay shape because he's so afraid and
what color is this ball is it is it
black and white check or is it brown
it's his hands have covered so much of
the ball that you can't tell okay all
right because he's so afraid of these
people who are now pursuing and what is
he trying to do with the ball is he
trying to get it into a net at the end
or is he trying to get into more like an
in zone like a like a like a general
Zone he's running towards
the the that the end where the goal
would be there but he has not yet
discovered it's kind of an area people
like people are removing the goal oh the
the soccer goal's gone well they're
they're so outraged they're removing the
Whole Net and the goal okay and they're
this guy doesn't deserve that kind of a
goal okay and then there happens to be
some sort of a
narrow
uh pole type device that's down there oh
but that's just I don't know why that's
there I think that's for advertising is
it one pole or is it two po Two Poles oh
it's two poles and then in between the
poles there's there was an there was a
sign because it was I think that was the
billboard for the soccer match okay and
then but there's that's getting yanked
down and leaving just a just a bare
skeleton of a of a narrow very narro and
what are they trying do with the to the
guy with the ball they trying to they're
trying to they're trying to get this guy
they're trying to grab him trying
they're trying to punish him for his
long-term hand Ball but he can pass it
to someone else as long as he backwards
or laterally right stop stop it I'm
going to tell you everything you need to
know okay you're so angry with this man
okay who's smooshing their soccer ball
that they want to take and they they
they do overtake him and they smash into
his shoulder area but not the head the
shoulder and Below area and then he gets
down on his knees almost and these other
the whole team is down clumped onto him
and just and they're they're on their
hands and knees and they're they're just
are you into it they're smooshing their
faces and their shoulders into each
other it's then does he take it and push
it back between his legs it's a it's I
would call it some sort of a a scrum of
sorts and they're smooshed against each
other and then the other team says hold
on I I I know what he's done is
indefensible but we have to we have to
take up for our boy and then everybody
joins the handballer in smooshing
against the other team until there's a
whole scrum aied clump of players
pushing against each other while almost
prone on the field and it's just it's a
quagmire of just pushing and grunting
I'm going to stop interrupting so he can
get through the whole thing pad padless
pushing and then and this goes on
because he obviously will continue until
the
end and then lo and behold somewhere
that you can't tell where but all of a
sudden the ball pops out towards the
back of the pile yeah and and and the
the a person and then they start chasing
this person and he gets scared so he's
like oh he throws it somebody to his
side or maybe behind him okay right yeah
but nobody runs ahead right can't throw
it forward and then then and then
everybody's going they said well we
don't want it what just happened to that
person in that big scrum of a thing well
I don't want that to happen again so I'm
going to throw it to the other guy and
they just keep ladling the ball to other
people to avoid another scrum and then
some I don't want that to happen again
and then
somebody doesn't have anybody to pass it
to and he's get and he's and he's
getting backed up and then you know what
he in a panic he just kicks the ball
yeah goes back to his soccer instincts
he just punts the ball MH just to get it
out of there and then the other team
catches it and they're like oh this is
fun we're on to something and they just
continue this forever in a day
yep until 80 minutes are
up so with no timeouts it just kind of
goes it never stops it's like soccer in
that way and there's blood on faces and
there's no protection except a handful
of the people who wear some sort of
thing I think to prevent getting the
wrestler ear a lot of them have the
cauliflower ear but they're look down
upon for I bet you wearing the I
certainly did yeah I certainly
did so uh at end there's a there's a
winner who won oh I don't
know South Africa won she was lated what
was the
score uh it was close it was within one
point to the very end how many points do
you get for getting into the place where
the goal used to be I'm going to say
five actually I don't know I don't know
and then I think if you kick it through
the goal post at a certain point uh I
think you get you can get other points
for that that are less than five did you
find yourself enjoy between two and
three I'm I'm guessing did you find
yourself enjoying it more than uh a
soccer and B American football yes
because it's got It's got the constant
activity of soccer but it's got the
violence of
Football H I mean guys were walking
around and there was just blood just
blood streaming off their face face like
they would been like they were a UFC
fighter or something yeah it's
intense I don't know the difference in
the rules of rul football but I watched
a bunch of Australian Rules Football
well we're not talking about that I just
can't I have no capacity for that I just
can't add another sport it's pretty
similar at all there's some differences
to the conversation this point there's
yellow cards and there's red cards I
will tell you that oh yeah okay so it is
just like soccer in that way yeah take
everything back it was um it was great I
was just thanking the rugby gods that
South Africa won because I was like man
this this whole thing is going to turn
sour if she doesn't get her
way I'm talking about the mom here but
she had a great time she had a great
time we all had a great time because
they won and do you think that you're
gonna play it professionally start we uh
watching
this oh no no it's a sport uh I ain't
got time for that
so you're still in a uh you're still in
a that was exhaust I mean I'm exhausted
just telling you about it we all are I
mean good gosh it is are you still in a
z absolute zero we're talking zero like
self self-motivated like there is no
scenario in which you by yourself would
make a decision to watch any sport I'm
talking like what if you're flipping
through I know there's no flipping
through we don't really flip through M
cornhole like the cornhole Championship
is on ESPN it's because there's no
flipping through if if there were still
flipping through I would stop on some
cornhole and like Lando's playing tennis
some now so I be I might stop on some
tennis and be like get in here boy look
at what what you trying to
do uh but I have no occa
like you know I have no occasion where
where sports are presented to me when
they're presented to me I learn a
lot you you wait for things to be
presented to you right and that's what
channel flipping was when you talk about
cornhole but yeah I I mean I don't miss
it I don't miss it and
um there's not a part of me that misses
it it's kind of like Sunday school
there's not a part of me that misses it
you think sports are as bad as Sunday
school no I'm not saying that what the
hell is wrong with you I'm not saying
that I'm just saying that I have a
similar experience of not missing them
from my life at all and it's really
important to other
people so but when you saw this person
who was like really passionately like
watching
it I loved it for her but like if I was
like okay because really I don't I I
watch very little Sports and I was
cheering very little Sports I was into
it and you know even the teams that I
pull for like okay I am technically like
a a Clippers fan I'm not really a fan of
any La football I don't really watch NFL
football but I don't find myself being
like I'm going to sit down and watch
this Clippers game on the on television
unless it's like in the playoffs when we
had the like the semi going to a game
that's fun I that was the last time that
I like because the boys were involved
like Lincoln and I would go to the games
with you and lot so like in person me
and Lincoln would watch the games we
didn't go to and that was fun
yeah I don't I never finish watching it
especially when you're an Inc State uh
fan a lot of times you get your hopes up
about you know yes oh we're going to do
this and we're going to do that and then
we get
disappointed so I don't find myself like
having watched it and then being like
that was an incredibly fulfilling
experience but like when I know that
State's going to be
playing somebody body I'm like I just
have this sense of it's not a sense of
obligation it's a like I still care I'm
able to understand that my caring about
it is not based in the rational part of
my brain there's an you have an
allegiance and there's a there's an
there's a sense of obligation that goes
along with it there's I think I I cut TI
completely there the potential Sports
when I moved out here there's the
potential
of the the team that you want to win
winning that's a special that's a
special feeling that I can't replicate
in other areas of my life like this
woman this South African woman right
it's a manufactured Victory by caring
about it yeah it's purely psychological
yeah I didn't have anything to do with
it but there's something about it now
then there are people who go a whole
like a like a many many steps my dad is
such a huge fan of Georgia
football like like such a massive fan of
Georgia football which is you know it's
a he's been a fan all his life it's a
good time to be a fan of Georgia
football surprised he doesn't own a
bulldog he's not a dog guy um but he
knows everything about it and like he's
on the forums you know what I mean like
he's yes yeah he's so fully invested and
he's got a friend who's also a big
Georgia fan who lives in a different
state and they're uh like on the phone
with each other while the game is being
played I'm glad he has somebody I'm glad
he I mean I would wish I would hope that
I would have something that I'm just as
passionate about as the people who are
that passionate about sports I think I
think that's a I think it's a good thing
you know it's like it's nice to have
something well there's few things and
there's few things that are that really
go that far like I honestly I don't have
anything that I'm that well think about
it like I'm so passionate about music I
think that's actually a really good
point how many times during the week the
experience is so different like if state
is playing and it's a close game and
again I'm just in there by myself lock
would watch stuff with me Shepherd
doesn't care so I'm kind of just like
watching it by myself Jesse doesn't care
and she's a Carolina grad anyway yeah
so I mean the level of intensity of my
reactions there's not another thing I'm
currently engaging with where I
literally would be like yes yes come on
yo yeah like what name another scenario
in my life right now where I will yell
that loudly about something I mean if I
go it's not a bit if I go to a
concert I'm G to do some yelling but
like what's he gonna sound like but I'm
going to be like
yay I mean I want what what what noise
do I make at a
concert uh
yeah it's a little it's stuff like that
right it's a that's a different it's a
different experience it's great it may
it may be a better experience but it's
not an
unfettered just release of like Primal
energy Primal Primal that's what I'm
getting
at what what other time like think about
it like what other time in your life cuz
I don't listen I'm not a road rage guy
of course I've never been to a battle of
the bands as many times as my fake rants
have gone viral and every time people
are cons are completely convinced that
they're real uh I don't actually ever
really get that way um in real life and
like I I've never I don't I don't I
don't road rage I don't get mad at
people and yell at people I don't do
that but sports are the like opportunity
for those emotions to come out mhm okay
in a way you know what I'm saying it's
there's and it is Primal I think Primal
is a good word because we don't have
opportunities for Primal experiences in
modern day life and so Sports is the
receptacle for people to act like fools
I mean let's just face it we're getting
really really excited and upset also
about things that we're just sitting
next to yeah it's a safe we're sitting
next to it place to cut loose we're
Mountain Time seating yeah looking at
the mountains the mountains are doing
all the work we're taking credit for it
we think that the underwear that we wore
that day is causing the quarterback to
do something different like we're idiots
we're morons yeah you are we think well
I yelled really loudly on third down and
they got a fault start I was responsible
for that that's a the close as you can
come to having any sort of influence is
maybe being loud enough on third down
but yeah when you're in your especially
when you're in your living room yeah you
have no influence you're in a completely
sealed bubble you have it's just a
completely isolated experience you give
you it's a safe space where you have
permission to just care deeply and to
engage these emotions and um but doing
it in a group that that's awesome too
but and I guess there are and I've been
told that there are there are like NC St
groups of people out here because you
know we live in Los Angeles lots of
people have moved from other places yeah
there are people who get together and
like watch State Games and I've never
thought I like well I'm
gonna that feels like a level of
commitment that I'm not willing to make
right but but if you met a guy or a gal
if you met a person who was really into
watching NC State athletics I might say
let's watch it together
yeah and they they invited you over like
lock and I had a lot of lot of fun
watching stuff together you know shepher
and I watch a lot of stuff together just
not sports but do you really want a
Wolfpack friend because I mean no I'm
just explo I don't they just don't win
enough this doesn't feel like a well
having someone to commiserate with I was
actually thinking about this my dad uh
being a self flatulation being a Georgia
fan is funny because I speaking of this
exact concept so okay you probably don't
know uh NC State beat Clemson in
football last week oh now typically this
would be good for us typically this
would be a huge deal but Clemson's not
any good this year oh but they've been
incredible
for millennium over a decade not
Millennium they they were they were
horrible 30 years ago but or 20 years
ago but you know since like the Dabo
Sweeney Sweeney whatever his name is you
know who I'm talking about he's like
your quintessential football coach and
you would know him if you saw him or or
heard him uh he's been there for like 12
years or whatever and they have had like
10- win Seasons they won the National
Championship twice they played in the
national championship multiple times the
only other teams that have been as good
as them in the past decade are Georgia
and Alabama right and this clip of him
on a radio show just went viral like
last night I found it and it was like a
kid or a younger person calling in and
complaining and all the thing the thing
that was on Twitter was just the his
rant this five minute rant from the
coach from the coach oh in response to
the kid in response to this kid and
basically it was
like I mean it was a little like he's so
frustrated because he's won the national
championship and he just got beat by
state and he's four and four like he's
not having a good year but they're all
calling for his head because he's not
having a good year even though he won 11
games last year and the thing he was
saying was uh
expectation versus appreciation he's
like we've been so good for so long that
it has changed into expectation and not
appreciation and so I was thinking about
my dad and how big of a fan of Georgia
he is and you know they won the National
Championship they haven't lost a g they
didn't lose a game last year they
haven't lost a game this year as of
recording
this and so being a fan of them becomes
hoping that they do not lose like we
have to win if we cuz in football you
lose and this kind of screws your whole
season up right yeah it's it's tough
being at the top so the psychological
thing like you talk about like do you
really want someone to watch state with
knowing that it's always going to be a
struggle we're going to have these
really passionate we're going to knock
off Carolina we're going to knock off
Duke every once in a while it's going to
be this passionate thing but we're going
to have these like we're going to kind
of be in the middle of the pack yeah in
a lot of ways we're going to have the
good years we're going to have the bad
years we're going have a lot of middle
of the road years so from a
psychological standpoint point which one
do you really really want do you want to
be the like we always win I'm I know I'm
saying this cuz I'm trying to make it
I'm trying to I'm trying to be I'm
trying to say I don't want I don't even
want us to be great because once you get
great then you just wait to lose MH okay
but my dad is sitting there on the phone
with his
buddy just like in fact my Cole was home
uh well Eli was home from school so my
my nephew Cole son and and they were
going to see Mom and Dad on a Saturday
that like the one Saturday that Eli was
going to be in town and Cole was like
this is like the window of time when I
could kind of take him down there and
hang out but it was during the Georgia
game okay and it was like it was like
Georgia and it was somebody they were
definitely going to beat but they
weren't winning at
halftime and Cole was just like you it's
like Dad can't he can't extricate
himself from it he cannot extricate
himself from this he's so in it yeah
he's like yes my grandson is here and I
dearly love my grandson but this is
Georgia football we're we're
experiencing right now and you know
charge $50 for un of course they won of
course they won H so I guess I don't
want I I don't know I don't know I think
I'm just going to keep being alone in my
house uh you know once a week
approximately to tune into an NC State
game whether it's football or basketball
that's where I draw the line I don't
move into any other sports okay getting
either really upset or really happy and
just a complete bubble that influences
no one but myself and then my wife who
will kind of walk by me and just kind of
look at me if I get especially loud
about
something that's me watching sports
yeah I'm just going to take not quite
like link watching rugby though and
thinking that it most closely relates to
soccer a little different a little
different a little
different I'm just going to take a hike
well you're it's probably literally it's
probably healthier uh it's my wreck this
week so um why don't you sing the wreck
theme song we're bringing it back 1888
Ear Pod one that's not it dude 1888 Ear
Pod
one what are you do what are you doing
it's a re the wreck theme song oh oh oh
oh oh what a what a what a Mor wck baby
wck baby 123 yeah yeah yeah you never
done it it's not really a song is it it
it is a song I
mean it's a portion of a song okay fine
I'll do it wreck baby wreck baby one two
three
4 okay uh my wreck is a YouTube video
which I just found if you just search
Andy Griffith Football story from
1953 I
think uh I think maybe that one will
give it to you what it was was football
you can also search that Andy Griffith
you know from The Andy Griffith Show mat
lock uh he has this routine from way
back then he basically I realized that I
was channeling the Andy Griffith it when
telling the uh my Rugby story because he
describes what football is would be like
if you had never seen it before yeah
from his like like backward his country
his country like backwards kind of just
so you know I did not pick up on the
fight
that what what that's what you were
referencing Andy oh well I wasn't you
weren't referencing it you're
unintentionally a vague recollection of
this but it's like it's a it's a comedy
routine right from Andy Griffith so yeah
uh if you if you like what I said about
rugby I was was just channeling the
1953 Andy Griffith what it was was
football I've seen what you're talking
about it's very funny and it's a little
you know it's just it's probably and
Andy's football routine probably started
much like Link's rugby routine you know
you it starts somewhere and then you you
polish it over time you know and you get
you make sure the different parts land
and that and then it becomes what Andy
did in 19 listen if you have any
feedback on anything that we said today
we want to hear from you you call us W
Baby W baby 1 2 3 4 1888 earpod 1 and
yeah cuz we want to get into it yeah we
like your voicemails let let us let us
know if you have any opinions on our
opinions on parents kids parenting
children we say at all on the podcast we
want to hear we would love to revisit
these things we ain't scared based on
your feedback we ain't scared let us
have
it and we'll talk catch you next week hi
Rhett and specifically link this is in
regards to your recent fanny pack
acquisition and your question about why
women are the only ones who get to carry
bags um there's a really good episode of
a podcast called articles of interest
and the episode's called pockets and
it's all about the history of pockets
and women's pockets and women's bags
that's my wreck bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of ear biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical
best